crucial dans l' équilibre économique de
livres cette période de fin d'année est
compliquée pour les libraires par
internet par téléphone le client doit
anticiper son achat faire sa commande
avant de venir le chercher sur internet
j'ai regardé sur le site de la librairie
la plus proche de chez moi
s'il avait le libre et ensuite je me
réserve et je suis venu le chercher le
lendemain j'ai pas accès à toute la
librairie bien sûr pour éventuellement
regarder ça suffit lâche avec je vous
les livre parce que j'en avais entendu
parler
non mais c'est quand même pas aussi
aussi coup je vais pouvoir avoir accès à
la librairie
c'est vrai que j'aime bien flâner dans
les rayons mais bon écoutez ça va pas
être définitif donc on retrouvera le
plaisir après dès l'instant où on peut
quand même acheter des livres c'est si
important à la librairie nouvelle
d'orléans on préfère le terme de
comptoir au mot anglais click and
collect ici en aucun cas la vente en
ligne ne peut remplacer le travail
d'accueil de liens de conseils du
libraire mais on s'adapte il ya une
satisfaction il y en a une seule c'est
qu'on conserve un contact avec nos
clients
économiquement c'est pas du thym je veux
dire ça représente 20 % notre chiffre
d'affaires avec une équipe qui est quand
même assez importante parce que comme
vous le voyez nous c'est pas un hangar
en fait c'est une librairie
c'est un endroit qui est fait pour se
promener dedans pour faire des
découvertes à notre service prend de
l'ampleur c'est l'expédition postale à
un centime d'euro c'est déjà près de 60
colis expédiés par jour